right there's a Fox News Alert we begin
tonight with what is a massive huge
mystery out of our nation's capital
Washington DC that is literally as we
speak reaching a fever pitch now just
who is the hearsay non whistleblower
whistleblower now tonight real clear
investigations Paul Sperry he is
reporting the details of this person's
identity let me be upfront and be very
very clear line of demarcation
there are things tonight that are so
scary that we can report we will
identify them we cannot independently
confirm Sperrys report we will not go
with the name of the identified person
unless we have final confirmation I can
confirm to you after making numerous
calls in the last hour this is the
individual that has the most talked
about in Washington as the whistleblower
and if Sperry is correct he turns out to
be correct and what he is reporting
tonight we are looking at a scandal of
monumental proportion in this country
one way or the other what we're watching
is this this speeding up process of this
impeachment wit witch-hunt with what we
know I can tell you tonight we cannot
continue until questions are answered
Republicans tonight must now demand
answers before anything moves forward
they must demand to know if in fact the
whistleblower was a deep state operative
they need to demand to know now we do
know there was contact with the corrupt
and cowardly and compromised congenital
liar
Adam shifts office we need to know what
that contact is every bit of that
contact we need to demand to know if
this person in fact whoever the non
whistleblower hearsay whistleblower is
did they abuse their power their
position at the Central Intelligence
Agency we need to know now if in fact
this person was working on a major
political agenda supporting a Democratic
candidate because we know there was the
support of a candidate from the IG which
we'll get to we need to demand to know
tonight the relationship and the contact
with his former boss and that would be
Brennan yeah his name comes up a lot
doesn't it
the whole thing what we know stinks to
high heaven we need to know if the tools
of our intelligence community were once
again weaponized and turned against the
President of the United States of
America we need to know if high-ranking
Obama officials were yet again involved
in a effort to overturn the will of the
people an election now we cannot and I
want to be clear confirm real clears
report but what is already being
reported is chilling we need answers and
we need them like yesterday we need to
know the identity of this non
whistleblower hearsay whistleblower we
need to know if they have an agenda we
need to know if the Intel community's
Inspector General when he said this
hearsay whistleblower favored a
political candidate that was a Democrat
what candidate was there any contact we
need we know there was contact with Adam
shifts office that makes him a fact
witness that makes him a compromise
chairman he is in no position to lead
any effort to impeach anybody except
himself
he needs to be investigated now we know
that a town that loves to leak has been
remarkably quiet on the whistleblowers
identity we know he was mentioned on the
floor of the house we know he was
mentioned in these secrets soviet-style
impeachment coup hearings we know that
everyone in the media I can speak from
people I know people at fake news CNN at
the area 51 Roswell Rachel Maddow
conspiracy channel M as DN C they know
this person's name it is now clear we
need to get to the truth in other words
we we the people need to know before
anything else moves forward
now it makes you wonder why did they
want to rush something as important as
impeachment why no due process for the
president who is
person that started this entire
Ukrainian what we now know to be a real
witch hunt because we do know the
interpretation that we were given by the
corrupt compromised cowardly and
congenital liar Adam Schiff was wrong it
was false we were told that the non
whistleblower hearsay whistleblower said
quid pro quos took place but we have the
transcript that transcript exonerates
president Trump completely that
transcript revealed these claims were
false by yes the compromised corrupt
congenital liar so we need to know
whether this person had in fact a
political agenda whether there was
collusion with shifts office whether
there was collusion with the Democratic
presidential candidate they supported we
need to know who that person was friends
with we need to know what contact he had
with John Brennan in other words we know
Brennan well he hates Donald Trump and
he's a former CIA director has a lot of
power probably and a lot of deep state
friends still working there and what
about Susan Rice her name is mentioned
in Sperrys article what about a
relationship with Adam Schiff where and
when did he meet with people in shifts
office what was said the chief's office
recommend hiring a lawyer was it a
specific lawyer did they recommend going
to the IG that that recommendation come
from the compromised corrupt ship's
office now we know Shiv lied about the
whistleblower we know he lied for three
years about Russia here's what he said
when he lied about knowing the
whistleblower we have not spoken
directly with the whistleblower we would
like to but I'm sure the whistleblower
has concerns that he has not been
advised as the law requires by the
inspector general or the Director of
National Intelligence just as to how he
is to communicate with Congress that was
another lie by the compromised corrupt
congenital liar Adam Schiff tonight we
need answers Republicans it is now time
for you to stand up for due process for
the Constitution of the United States
for the rule of law for equal
application of our laws and
application as well that would work now
you got to do your jobs we need as a
country to get to the bottom of this
impeachment is a really really important
issue for the American people because
what is being reported by real clear
investigations on top of what we already
know it is shocking if it turns out that
Paul Sperry and real clear
investigations is right it would
represent another confirmed coup attempt
and according to the report again this
is what they're reporting we have not
confirmed he would be an Obama holdover
work with Joe Biden John Brennan and as
close ties to Schiff and his his team
VAX Perry reports that the individual
was a former colleague to members of
shifts congressional staff and that's
not all they are reporting we have not
confirmed that he had ties to the DNC
operative who helped the Clinton
campaign coordinate with the country
Hugh Crain that's how deep Sperrys
allegations go the media needs to get
off their backsides and now begin to do
their job and seek truth remember the
political report January 11 2017 that we
frequently reference DNC operative who
colluded with Ukraine yes to bolster the
Clinton campaign and a Ukrainian Court
confirming Ukraine did in fact
coordinate with the DNC and they
colluded to help Hillary Clinton and
interfere in the 2016 elections that was
Ukrainian Court decision we know the
whistleblower well used to work with
that Ukrainian individual we talked
about but there's more in Sperrys claims
he says this individual hated Trump was
not shy about sharing those opinions in
fact according to this real clear report
he was previously accused of leaking
information to damage president Trump
does he have an agenda it's obvious all
indications now point to a possibility
maybe likelihood of another deep state
political hit job we need to get to the
bottom of what we know though and what
we know is what was the contact with the
corrupt and compromise congenital liar
Adam shifts office what was the
relationship with Joe Biden and any of
the other candidates what's the
relationship with Brennan he used to be
his boss
no wonder chef recuse
refused to call this guy oh we don't
need to talk to him anymore because he
knows Republicans would ask those
questions the reports of truth tonight
it's even worse than what we do know in
other words we know he's not a real
whistleblower well you know he's
anti-trump a deep state bureaucrat we
know he's a hearsay whistleblower okay
he's doing this because he hates Donald
Trump and he thinks he knows better than
we the American people so it's time for
the corrupt compromised cowardly atom
shift the congenital liar and his allies
to come clean
Republicans must now demand that and
that is the subject of our monologue
tonight it is clear tonight in America
that the Democratic Party and the media
mob and the deep state they have been
and continue to work hand in hand they
want to fundamentally destroy the very
foundation of this great Democratic
Republic that is now indisputable at
this point after top-secret trial no due
process
flagrant witness tampering predetermine
outcome spurred by an apparent partisan
deep state operative masquerading as a
whistleblower
we know that speaker name only Nancy
Pelosi is now asking her fellow members
of Congress to rush through and
authenticate this secret soviet-style
impeachment coup attempt you have House
members will now have to decide whether
or not the corrupt compromise congenital
liar Adam Schiff will get a green light
to take his top secret witch-hunt public
most lawmakers have not been allowed to
attend the closed-door hearings even
view evidence even review transcripts
yet they'll now be asked to authenticate
a phony closed-door process that they
know very little about essentially it is
a vote be very clear this vote tomorrow
this vote will be a vote for a process
that is run by Adam shift that guy is
the single most corrupt the biggest liar
in Washington DC and that sewer swamp
which says a lot that guy spent two-plus
years right there blatantly lying in
public on TV saying he has all the
evidence of Trump Russia collusion you
might remember
of these lies because we had four
separate investigations the FBI
investigation house Intel investigation
bipartisan Senate investigation and the
molar report that contradict what he was
telling us take a look there is already
in my view ample evidence in the public
domain on the issue of collusion if
you're willing to see it if you want to
blind yourself then you can look the
other way I could certainly say with
confidence that there is significant
evidence of collusion between the
campaign and Russia I've been very clear
over the last year year and a half that
there is ample evidence of collusion in
plain sight no evidence in clear sight
that's why he's a congenital liar those
lies didn't stop there this is the guy
who completely fabricated the transcript
had to make it up of the president's
phone call with the president of Ukraine
in an official White House hearing
that's the guy who lied once again on TV
about not having contact with the
hearsay non whistleblower whistleblower
and by the way he is the guy who's been
tampering with virtually every witness
brought before his secret soviet-style
impeachment coup attempt inquiry take a
look I have never in my life seen
anything like what happened today I mean
they've been bad at most of these
depositions but to interrupt us
continually to coach the witness to
decide whether or not what what we're
gonna be able to ask the witness I mean
we don't even get any witnesses at this
point and it doesn't like look like
we're gonna get any ever but to not let
us ask questions I've never ever had
that and to see someone coach a witness
you know this isn't the first time that
you know shifts very good at coaching
witnesses remember he also met with the
whistleblower so this is this is just
unprecedented now whether you're a
Republican or Democrat your goal if
you're talking about impeaching a
president needs to be to find the truth
to have due process you don't shut down
a witness you know coach a witness you
don't stop a witness from answering a
question because you don't like the
question in fact if you have any
fidelity at
all two objective truth common sense
reason justice the constitutional
process you must implement due process
in any trial or investigation that's why
passed impeachment proceedings in short
for example Newt Gingrich guaranteed
Bill Clinton the Democrats lake a
guaranteed Richard Nixon that they were
not stripped of their fundamental rights
that is now happening here but Lau the
latest resolution does the exact
opposite and that's the one that'll be
voted on by the Democrats tomorrow it's
going to be interesting to watch it
would grant yes the congenital liar the
compromised corrupt Adam Schiff and his
fellow Democrats the power to veto any
witness any evidence any procedure they
basically can do anything they want
there's no due process is there any
fair-minded Democratic Congress people
out there tonight
when you put your hand on the Bible and
you swear to uphold to protect the
Constitution of the United States of
America is this what you had in mind is
this what due process looks like to you
is this really the best way to get to
the truth and at the end of the day if
you decide to sacrifice American ideals
prince the principles constitutional
order you will be creating a dangerous
precedent and what are you gaining well
we actually have one honest Democrat
from New Jersey who plans to vote
against the witch hunt tomorrow
something up purposely perfectly to CBS
News from New Jersey and obviously he
says he's going to be impeached and it
will go to the Senate and I believe in
the Senate it will he will be meeting
the president vindicated and that's
congressman Van Druce from New Jersey
and he also says quote I also think we
spent a lot of money and a lot of time
and haven't been able to get a whole lot
of things done
andrew is one of maybe five Democrats so
far who are not supporting this corrupt
impeachment lacking due process
resolution that would include Andrew
Anthony Brenda C from New York
Jared Goldman Maine Kendra horn Oklahoma
Colin Peterson from Minnesota what do
they all have in common they all
represent districts won by Donald Trump
in 2016 and they're not alone there are
31 law may
that represent purple red districts
carried by the president well these
lawmakers right there will they vote to
override the will of their constituents
based on a one-sided secret trial run by
well a compromised corrupt congenital
liar by the name of Adam Schiff sadly at
least one of the people on this list
New York Congressman max Rose is ready
right now to impeach President Trump and
he believes President is guilty until
proven innocent telling the new magazine
quote the president says he's innocent
so all we're saying is prove it oh I
didn't know it worked that way that way
you really believe congressman Rose you
believe that guilty until proven
innocent this is why Republicans Kevin
McCarthy House Majority Leader says they
will take back the house in 2020 and as
leader McCarthy pointed out the GOP they
only need 19 seats to win that majority
and then Pelosi's